non c'est vraiment les black eyed peas
vent oui ils sont là ils sont avec nous
et thank you thank you very much
ça veut dire merci beaucoup on est
vraiment très très content de vous avoir
ce soir
happy to see you tonight is no 1
à chaud je fais du groupe
[Applaudissements]
si vous dit vous savez qu'il est black
eyed peas je vous donner des chiffres 40
millions d'albums à 31 millions de
singles c'est mythique
rollier groupe international à faire
trois stades de france 2 albums bien sûr
sienne et the beginning certifié disque
de diamant en france et on est très très
heureux de vous avoir le titre
ilike besson ils ont décidé que l'entv
avant la télévision réputation
[Applaudissements]